nonsense
okay we're going to pause it there and
we're going to bring in sound codes our
Deputy political editor who's enjoying
all of this enormously Sam
um prime minister's questions what are
you looking forward to what do you think
we may see well it's the penultimate one
of my God quite turbulent 2022 and I I
for me what's been interesting in the
last few weeks watching those initial
battles between Rishi sunak and kirstama
is that
actually kissed on and sort of found his
line of argument
um and it keeps coming back to it and
it's in it's a it's a critique of
whether or not Rishi sunak is is strong
and given the event of the last few days
actually I wonder whether or not he goes
right back there because look at the
climb down on housing targets that climb
down on uh no one shall wind even even
look yesterday at the way the government
wasn't able to put up a fight against
Labor's attempts to force the disclosure
of documents around Michelle Moon the
the conservative peer and what was going
on with PPE it's not clear to me that
Rishi sunak has a great deal of
parliamentary Firepower to get through
difficult things that he might want to
do in the coming weeks or months so I
think from from kierstama's point of
view that line about whether or not uh
richardsonac is Tough Enough is is one
that certainly uh he'll be able to point
to events in the last few days when he
when he talks about and I think this is
going to be a theme of 2023 but PM he's
always reflects the kind of urgent
questions of the day and I mean this
just strikes uh you look at the misery
that people are facing the fact that
some people are going out um taking
industrial action you've got what the
knock-on effect of what that's going to
mean for millions of people in the
run-up to Christmas I think the Tories
want to point to some opinion polling
from you gov suggesting that uh perhaps
attitudes to strikes over Christmas is
hardening I've been talking to pollsters
about that there's a big health warning
from the way the Tories are trying to
spin these polls because the question
being asked is about whether or not
strikes specifically just before
Christmas are a good idea people don't
like that it doesn't necessarily tell
you the underlying attitudes to
Industrial action which has been a
little bit more Even Stevens in the last
few weeks but I think Richie sunak will
want to look at as uh Tris Williams were
saying the link between the unions which
are giving donations to kirst armor and
uh and the labor leader himself as a way
of capitalizing on that nervousness
among some uh about whether the labor
would stand up to them as Blended or
whether they're still restages of Jeremy
corbyn's Stellar government prime
ministers on his feet that's listening
further such meetings later today
thank you very much Mr Speaker yesterday
the United Kingdom in its current form
turned 100 years old but neither the
Prime Minister nor the leader of the
labor party seemed to recognize the
challenge of the Supreme Court ruling as
to the very nature of the union he
didn't answer me two weeks ago so can
the Prime Minister clarify if he still
believes the UK is a voluntary Union and
if so can he explain the Democratic
route by which the people of Scotland
can choose whether to stay in it or not
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker we fully respect the
decision of the Supreme Court and
believe strongly in the United Kingdom
and as I said to The Honorable lady last
time we will work constructively with
the Scottish government to deliver for
the people of Scotland
thank you Mr Speaker Financial scams the
most common form of crime causing
immense emotional and financial distress
to millions of people and government
efforts in this matter of tend to focus
on making sure that scammers can't
launder their proceeds of crime and that
victims get compensation both of those
are really important but they're acting
after the scams happened does my right
honorable friend the Prime Minister
agree with me that government
departments regulators and Industry
perhaps Guided by an anti-scams task
force could do far more to stop scams
happening in the first place and will he
meet with me to talk about this
well Mr Speaker honorable friend is
right to highlight the hurt that
scammers and fraudsters can cause we are
working closely with industry to block
more fraudulent calls from reaching the
public and importantly our new Online
safety bill will place duties on the
largest internet companies to tackle
scam ads I would be happy to meet with
my honorable friend to discuss further
we know comes the leader of the
opposition kills farmer
thank you Mr Speaker can I start by
welcoming the new member of parliament
for the city of Chester
[Applause]
it's the best result for labor in the
105 years we've been fighting that seat
look forward to working with her to
build a better future for the people of
Chester
promise to come
that causes a year this week without
asking a single voter the Prime Minister
broke that Promise by scrapping
mandatory targets
what changed
Mr Speaker let me start by also
welcoming The Honorable lady to her to
her place now The Honorable gentleman
comes here every week and I know he's
focused on the process and the politics
but I don't think he's actually taken
the time to read the detail of what we
are doing to improve our planning system
so let me let me just explain what we
are doing we are Mr Speaker we are
protecting the green belt
and we're providing support and
protection for local neighborhood plans
the shadow housing secretary said she
said Community should have control over
where homes are built and what sort of
homes are built that's my position
that's her position what's his position
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker does he really
expect us to believe that the member for
chipping Barton are the member for the
Isle of Wight are cheering him on
because he's going to build more homes
pull the other one
I'll tell him I'll tell him what changed
his back bench has threatened him and as
always the blancmange Prime Minister
wobbled
heated a grubby deal with a handful of
his MPS and sold out the aspirations of
those who want to own their own home
was it worth it
Mr Speaker as ever as ever engaging in
the petty personality politics
not not not not not focused on the
substance again let me explain what
we're doing we're delivering what I said
we would do we're protecting the
character of local communities
we're cracking down on land banking an
irresponsible developers and we're
giving people a greater say in their
decisions just this week Mr Speaker just
this week on Monday The Honorable
gentleman said the government should be
giving people more power and control
now now now he seems to be opposing that
policy it's a
it's a flops me even for him it's pretty
speaker he's forgotten last week
last week I offered him labor votes to
pass these housing targets
because this is bigger than Politics the
former housing secretary on their side
said scrapping mandatory targets would
this is his words from their side of the
house be a colossal failure of political
leadership no wonder he doesn't want to
fight the next election Mr Speaker the
author of the manifesto that they all
stood on said it would cut building by
40 percent perhaps even more why would
he rather [ __ ] house building than
work with us
to get those targets through
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we're not going to work with
the labor party on housing you know why
we'll have a look at their records on
housing
conservative mayor in five years built
sixty thousand affordable homes
the current labor mayor half of that
amount
in Wales in Wales We Want to Build 12
000 homes what are labor delivering half
of that Mr Speaker
the labor party talks the conservatives
deliver
Mr Speaker as ever too weak to stand up
to his own side of behalf of the country
Mr Speaker I I noticed there was another
U-turn last night this time on wind
farms actually I agree with that one but
it's the no issue or which he won't give
in to his back benches
now Mr Speaker how did his colleague
baroness moan end up with nearly 30
million pounds of taxpayers money in her
bank account
Mr Speaker let me say like everyone else
I was absolutely shocked to read about
the allegations
right
[Applause]
it's it's absolute it's absolutely right
that she is no longer attending the
House of Lords and therefore no longer
has the conservative whip
that again the one thing we know about
Donald gentleman he is a lawyer he
should know there's a process in place
it's right that that process concludes I
hope that it's resolved promptly but I
say one thing Mr Speaker because he I
tell him he'd be mentioned I'll tell him
what is weak I tell him what is weak
it's not being
[Applause]
taken some advice from Gordon Brown
lately why doesn't why doesn't he listen
to a former minister in Gordon Brown's
government who just said why does the
labor party refuse to stand up for
workers and businesses like pubs and
restaurants who will lose business as a
result of the train strikes labor should
stand up for working people if he's
strong that's what he should do
Mr Speaker it may not seem like it but
he's supposed to be the Prime Minister
this morning this morning his transport
secretary said that his Flagship
legislation on strikes this is what he
said this morning his transport
secretary might want to listen to this
is clearly is clearly not going to help
with the industrial action we're facing
he should stop grandstanding stop
sitting on his hands get around the
table and resolve these issues and
everyone can see what's happening here a
Tory politician got their hands on
hundreds of millions in taxpayers money
and then provided Duff PPE and he says
he's shocked he was the chancellor he he
signed the checks how much is he going
to get back
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker it's right that he brought up
legislation with regard to strikes and
I'm very happy to address it actually so
hard-working families right now in this
country are facing challenges the
government has been reasonable it's a
it's everybody
Gates is higher than the private sector
but if the union leaders to continue to
be unreasonable then it is my duty to
take action to protect the lives and
livelihoods of the British public and
that's why Mr Speaker since I became
prime minister I have been working for
new tough laws to protect people from
this disruption that's the legislation
he's asking about will he now confirm
that he'll stand up for working people
and that he and his party will back that
legislation
Mr Speaker he's obviously he's obviously
not heard what is transport secretary
said about that legislation this morning
and it's obvious why they're so opposed
to Labor's plans to clean up Westminster
they all voted for tax Rises for working
people while one of their unelected
peers pocketed Millions flogging dodgy
PPE should be ashamed Mr Speaker I want
to raise something that is worrying
parents across the country
Hearts our hearts go out
bulldrum who've tragically died from the
outbreak of strep a in recent weeks I'm
very happy to work with the government
on this
so can he take the opportunity to update
the country on the measures the country
is taking to keep children safe this
winter
well Mr Speaker my thoughts were of
course with the families of the children
who have sadly lost their lives we are
seeing a higher number of cases from
strepe this year compared to usual uh
what I can say is that the NHS who I've
sat down to talk about this are working
very hard to make sure parents are aware
of the symptoms that they should be
looking out to because this can be
treated appropriately with the
antibiotics there are no current
shortages of drugs available to treat
this and they're well-established
procedures in place to ensure that that
remains the case and the UK sha are
monitoring the situation at PACE and
what they have confirmed is that there
is this is not a new strain of strep a
so people should be reassured about that
there is no reason to believe that it's
become more lethal a more resistant to
antibiotics so the most important thing
for parents to do is look out for the
symptoms and get the treatment that is
available for them
thank you Mr Speaker Airbnb type short
term let's provide a positive experience
for many holiday makers but too many
cause real issues for local communities
in Westminster we have 13
000 Airbnb properties alone does my
writing before friend the Prime Minister
agree with me that it is now time to
consider a registration scheme managed
by local authorities so councils can
properly manage this growing sector
leveling up secretary has indeed said
that we will deliver a new tourist
accommodation registration scheme
something I know my honorable friend has
asked for it will increase appropriate
regulation of the sector better
understand and monitor the impact on
local communities and we will also
consult on whether planning permissions
should be required for new short-term
holiday lets especially in tourist hot
spots can I welcome the new leader of
the SMP and thank you Blackford
previously Stephen
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker I wish to begin by
paying tribute to my friends and
colleagues the right honorable member
for Ross Sky I walk over here
and Duty for the last five years Mr
Speaker he is a giant of the Scottish
independence movement Mr Speaker not one
two
executive Tory Prime Ministers indeed he
was on to his fourth in recent weeks
into that latest prime minister I have a
very simple question what does he
consider to be the greatest achievement
of the conservative party in government
since 2019 leaving the single Market in
customs Union ending freedom of movement
denying Scotland through democracy or
getting the labor party to agree with
all of the above foreign
Mr Speaker can I start by offering my
genuine and warm heartfelt best wishes
to the right honorable member for Ross
guy in La Carver I know I know the whole
house will miss his weekly contributions
um and May and may I may I also
congratulate or join the first minister
in congratulating The Honorable
Gentleman on his appointment as a
Westminster leader of the SNP I look
forward to a constructive debate uh with
him across the dispatch box and Mr
Speaker the answer to this question is
actually very simple for things that we
are most proud of in the last couple of
years is making sure that we protected
this country through the pandemic with
with furlough and with the fastest
vaccine rollout
Mr Speaker far be it for me to offer
advice to a near billionaire but he's
going to have to up his game and here's
why because in the last 15 minutes a
poll has landed which shows the support
for Scottish independence has now hit 56
percent
age National Party
of 50 so in that context can I ask the
Prime Minister does he consider that
increasing energy bills on households
and energy rich Scotland by a further
500 pounds will cause those poll numbers
to rise or to fall
well Mr Speaker what we're delivering
for households across the United Kingdom
including those in Scotland is 55
billion pounds of support with energy
bills it will save a typical homeowner
about 900 pounds under their bills this
winter with extra support for the most
vulnerable and that is Mr Speaker an
example of the United Kingdom and the
union delivering for people in Scotland
yeah thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
Eden Project North is now
getting right to the end of the process
it's gone through right to the leveling
up stage two
it has planning permission it has land
allocation it has everything that's
going to offer the north of England
Prime Minister when are we going to be
getting the Eden Project North
well Mr Speaker my honorable friend I
think the whole house knows honorable
friend has been a
uh for for Eden North for some time I
was pleased to work with him in my
previous role he knows I can't comment
on any specific bid but I know that the
secretary of state will be making these
decisions by the end of the year and I
wish him and everyone involved in the
project every success even foreign thank
you most people and businesses in
Northern Ireland accept the need for the
protocol I want to see negotiated
pragmatic solutions to the various
challenges while there has been a clear
Improvement in the music between the UK
and the European Union over recent weeks
there is a growing frustration and
concern at the slow rate of actual
progress in those talks so what steps
could the Prime Minister take to inject
some momentum into those negotiations
and indeed can I encourage him to visit
Northern Ireland as soon as possible
perfectly before Christmas to engage
with local stakeholders around the
protocol and also to hear views of how
the assembly can be restored via reform
well can I thank my The Honorable
gentleman for his his question and and I
enjoyed meeting him recently to discuss
these issues let me give him and the
people of Northern Ireland my Assurance
that I want to see the issues with the
protocol resolved as quickly as possible
I do believe that if people enter into
these talks that we are having in the
spirit of Goodwill and pragmatism that
we can indeed find a way through my
right normal friend the foreign
secretary and Vice President stefkovic
are in regular dialogue and I will take
on board his suggestion to come visit
Northern Ireland to discuss these things
in person
thank you Mr Speaker we just had small
business Saturday where we marked the
important impact more businesses have on
our local communities I like many of my
colleagues have spoken to these
businesses and heard just how great
their concerns are for their future when
the Prime Minister was Chancellor
earlier this year he went with me to
Fred Hallam in Beeston a business
established in 1908 smes such as this
faceted pandemic and now Rising energy
costs can the Prime Minister lay out how
he run into all businesses such as Fred
Hallen will be supported in the coming
months so that they may Thrive and
continue to provide vital goods and
services to my constituents in broxtape
well I know my honorable friend is a
fantastic champion of his local
businesses it was was a privilege to
visit Beeston and Hallens earlier this
year with him and I remember we
discussed then some of the things we
were planning to do which are now going
to make a big difference saving
businesses hundreds or thousands of
pounds with their energy bills through
our relief scheme this winter our
business rates tax cuts package worth
over 13 billion particularly impacting
retail businesses and with initiatives
like the annual investment allowance and
help to grow we can take his small
businesses to a whole new level I look
forward to working with him on that but
thank you Mr Speaker a Visa for the
select committees both the author of The
governmental national food strategy and
the United Nations Festival Rapids on
the right of food a call for Universal
three School meals to possess the issue
of the four million children hungry in
the UK will the Prime Minister meet with
me to discuss our investments in
Universal free School meals will benefit
children and their families in Liverpool
West Derby and the country and at no
extra cost of the taxpayer
Mr Mr Speaker I know this is an issue on
which honorable gentleman has campaigned
for some time and he's right to
highlight the importance of making sure
our children have access to food that's
why I'm proud that we introduce not just
uh an expansion of free School meals but
also the holiday activity and food
program I'm always interested in more
ideas where we can go further I look
forward to hearing from him Davis thank
you Mr Speaker whether on defense with
orcas trade with CP TPP or diplomacy
with asean I know this government
recognizes the importance of the
indo-pacific to the UK's security and
prosperity but the challenges that exist
whether they are ballistic missile tests
or the Belton Road are deeply
interconnected so can the Prime Minister
confirm that the indo-pacific remains a
UK priority and that he will take a
holistic approach uh within government
to meet the challenges and capture the
opportunities that exist in the region
well Mr Speaker last year's integrated
review set out our indo-pacific tilt
with regard foreign policy I reaffirmed
this government's commitment to that
tilt in a speech at the Lord mayor's
dinner just the other week and he's
right to highlight both the economic and
security importance of the region he
should be reassured that we're pursuing
not just free trade agreements
bilaterally but also cptpp the orcas
partnership and indeed hopefully a a new
partnership with regard to our future
combat air system all evidence that we
are delivering on the tilt
Mr Speaker members across this house
know the devastating impact of bank
branch closures on our communities but
as blank Banks flee the high streets our
free cash machines disappear with them
putting the most vulnerable hardest
it cannot be right that a quarter of
ATMs charge people to access their own
money
so will the Prime Minister join dozens
of his own back benches today in backing
my prosparty Amendment and ensure that
everyone has free access to their hard
earned money
well Mr Speaker this government is
indeed legislating to safeguard access
to cash and that's what the financial
services and markets bill this afternoon
will do through a very significant
intervention I also I'm also pleased
that we put in place initiatives with
the industry to subsidize free to use
ATMs in deprived areas and almost 50
communities are benefiting from our new
shared cash facilities because access to
cash is important and that's what our
new bill will deliver the Manchester
thank you Mr Speaker very much welcome
the government's commitment to its
Hospital buildings program can the
Primacy clarify what criteria will be
applied for the allocation of those new
hospitals and what have we done in line
with the primus's personal commitment on
a merits-based system of government
because my Hospital in Medway serves
half a million people and is the busiest
Hospital a e in Kent we have some of the
highest health inequalities in the
country we're one of the hardest hit
areas in Medway during covert 19. we
need our fair share allocation of
resources in Medway will the Prime
Minister visit Medway hospital for with
me and fellow local MPS to look at our
urgent need
well my uh minable friend is a fantastic
Champion for his local area but
especially uh for his local hospital
he'll know that I can't comment on any
specific scheme but I can tell him that
submissions to be one of the new
hospitals are currently being reviewed
in the department and an announcement
will be made shortly
very Kelly Floyd yeah yeah thank you Mr
Speaker on small business Saturday I was
delighted to name Daisy Rose coffee
houses the city of Durham's small
business of the Year 2022 after a public
vote in my inaugural award but like so
many small businesses Daisy Rose coffee
house is the beaten heart of the local
community and the Cornerstone in their
High Street but so many business owners
that I meet with feel utterly ignored by
the government as they're clobbered by
outdated business rates year after year
the government must pick a side are they
going to continue with the to back the
online Giants or will they join the
labor party and back small business and
scrap and replace the outdated business
rates yeah yeah
well Mr Speaker can I congratulate Daisy
Rose for winning uh their award and
being the Beating Heart of their High
Street I very much hope that they will
benefit and I'm almost certain they will
from our discounts on business rates our
retail hospitality and leisurely uh
relief gives us 75 discount on business
rights in the next financial Year and
that comes on top of the support that
we'll be providing Daisy Rose and others
with their energy bills with bills being
about half of what they would have
otherwise been without our support
[Applause]
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker can I
thank you and colleagues across the
house
for your kindness and encouragement in
recent weeks
The Honorable friend the Prime Minister
this afternoon to recommit the
government he leads to our ambition of
leveling up communities in every part of
our great United Kingdom and to that end
could I invite my right honorable friend
to come and visit my Bournemouth West
constituency and see the latest school
rebuild the multi-million pound rebuild
of the oak Academy which will stand as a
lasting tribute of opportunity to the
people I have the privilege of serving
in this house
well Mr Speaker can I say that it's very
nice to hear from my right honorable
friend today and and he's absolutely
right there is no better way to spread
opportunity around the country than by
investing in our children's future uh
I'm absolutely delighted that Oak
Academy in his constituency is
benefiting from our school rebuilding
program and I will certainly ask my
office to keep his kind invitation in
mind
yeah yeah thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker I read this matter before but
despite meeting with our previous prime
minister in 2020 this matter has not
progressed
in 1984 I was observing police officer
on the Met Fallen place when on the 17th
of April WPC Von Fletcher was shot in
the back and killed where he was placing
a political demonstration outside the
Libyan Embassy no one has ever in charge
in connection with her mother
in November last year delivering his
judgment in a civil case a senior high
Court Justice Mr Justice Spencer said
I'm satisfied that on the balance of
probabilities that the defendant salima
Brook is jointly liable for the shooting
of WPC Von Fletcher on the doctrine of
common design we all the frame Minister
meet with me to see how this case may be
taken forward and finally bring those
responsible for the murder of Yvonne to
Justice in a criminal court
oh can I Thank The Honorable gentleman
for his continued work on this case as
he said it's something that he has
raised before uh he'll appreciate that
why I can't speak in detail on any
particular case there are differences in
the standard of proof required for civil
and criminal proceedings you know that
said the CPS will consider any new
information that is referred to them by
the police in relation to this case and
of course I'd be very happy to meet with
him Jackie Doyle price
[Applause]
[Music]
returning to the theme of communities
being able to decide where to build in
thorough we embrace the our obligations
to deliver more new homes and it's arena
Essex we have an application to deliver
two and a half thousand new homes ready
to go however there is a standing
objection to any development over 300
holes from National highways because of
the impact on Junction 30 then 25. could
I ask my right honorable friend what
advice he gives to her at Council as to
how they can deliver their housing
obligations with this National
constraint
well well Mr Speaker I thank my
honorable friend for her question then
she highlights a great example of a
council that is trying to do the right
thing and put the right homes in the
right places they should have our
support if I'd ask her please to write
to my right and we'll friend the
leveling up secretary with the details
of the issue so we can give her a full
response but praise her accountable to
try and make sure that we can build the
homes where we need them damn Daniel
Johnson thank you Mr Speaker
why can't the government process Asylum
claims within six months thereby saving
5.6 million pounds a day on Asylum
seeking Seekers accommodation granting
Asylum to those who need it quickly and
stopping the abuse of the system which
currently has a backlog of 147
000 Asylum claims
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker what we are doing is
significantly increasing the number of
case workers we are on call to double it
by next spring with several hundred
already in place and and she is right
that the process takes longer than it
should often that is because people are
able to exploit some of the rules in our
system uh and make sequential claims
that is exactly the type of thing that
the Home Secretary and I are working on
fixing and I look forward to having the
party opposite support when we do
thank you Mr Speaker they've been more
reported deaths and adverse reactions
following mRNA vaccination 18 months
than there has been to every
conventional vaccine administered
worldwide for the last 50 years and
given that mRNA vaccines are not
recommended for pregnant women or those
who are breastfeeding with my right
honorable friend overturn the big
pharma-funded mhra's recent
recommendation that these experimental
vaccines are administered to children as
young as six months of age
well Mr Speaker let me first say that I
believe covert vaccines are indeed safe
and effective
and no no vaccine covert or otherwise
will be approved unless it meets the UK
Regulators standards of safety quality
and Effectiveness we have an independent
body the jcvi determines which age
groups the vaccine is recommended for
use in as part of the vaccination
program and of course the ultimate
decision will lie with parents
thank you Mr Speaker during covid we all
applauded our NHS nurses who put their
lives on the line to help millions of
our constituents and our loved ones but
we now know that at the same time
Tory Spirits were helping themselves
using their connections and Kobe to help
themselves to millions of pounds of
public money why is the prime minister
on the side of the spivs and not on the
side of the nurses
[Applause]
Mr Speaker what everyone was doing at
the time was working as hard and as
quickly as they could to get the PPE to
to get to get the PPE needed for our
Frontline workers including our nurses
actually there was an independent
procurement process ministers were not
involved in the decision making but it
was right it was right Mr Speaker though
that people gave their ideas about where
to get them from indeed the shadow
Chancellor herself suggested that we
should get PPE from a law firm she
suggested we should get ventilators from
a football agent everyone was trying as
hard as they can we should remember the
context and stop playing politics
foreign
Mr Speaker two weeks ago more than 350
people attended a meeting in skegness to
discuss the use of five seafront hotels
to house Asylum Seekers they were United
in their view that there was a long-term
economic impact and a pressure on public
services they told me loud and clear
that like the prime minister they think
hotels are the wrong place for Asylum
Seekers does he agree with me that the
government needs urgently to lay out a
plan that moves beyond the use of hotels
puts Asylum seekers in the right place
for them and the right place for Coastal
communities such as those in skegness I
completely agree with my honorable
friend that we are now spending six
million pounds a day housing Asylum
Seekers hotels are incredibly expensive
we will urgently bring forward proposals
to reduce the pressure but as he knows
as I know the best way to solve this
problem sustainably is to reduce the
number number of illegal migrants coming
to the United Kingdom and that's what
this government will deliver we sold
more thank you Mr Speaker audit Wales
has confirmed that the Welsh labor
government responded well and got on
with a job of delivering value for
taxpayers money can the Prime Minister
tell the house what first attracted him
to awarding billion pounds of covered
contracts to Tory donors and supporters
and what is he doing to claw taxpayers
money back
[Applause]
again Mr Speaker we delivered 32 billion
pieces of PPE to the front line at a
time when there was a global shortage as
I've already said everyone tried to do
their bit we heard recommendations from
the shadow Chancellor but it was right
that hers and everyone else's
suggestions went through an independent
process where ministers were not
involved in the decisions Robin Walker
Josh McAllister's independent review of
children's social care has been with the
government since May and I understand
there's been some disappointment but the
response to it won't be published before
Christmas but can the Prime Minister
insure given the very important
recommendations about some of the most
vulnerable children in our society and
the families who support them the people
who support them but there will be a
strong and robust government response as
early as possible in the New Year yes my
uh my honorable friend not obviously
knows this subject area well he's right
to highlight the importance of making
sure that we do provide good quality
support to vulnerable children the
report has a lot of interesting
suggestions in it and he's right and I
can commit to him we will respond in due
course final question thank you very
much prime minister over 70 of Northern
Ireland's International tourists arrived
to Dublin and travel across the land
border the UK government's proposed
electronic travel authorization would
likely mean the north being struck off
the itinerary of operators and many
independent Travelers and the last thing
we need is a barrier to one of our
biggest economic drivers to say nothing
of the impact of non-irish and British
people living in Ireland members from
across the house have acknowledged that
our border isn't a normal one will the
Prime Minister commit to scrapping this
unworkable proposal
Mr Speaker I can give the old lady my
Assurance that we'll remain very
committed to the common travel area and
indeed do not want to see any checks on
the island of Ireland and that's why
we're working very hard to resolve the
issues with the protocol and ensure
Northern Ireland's place in the United
Kingdom
Excel
obviously it's not on this field right
let us go on to the Urgent question
Dave Margaret Hodge
well as the hassle Commons empties after
prime minister's questions let's just
reflect on what we heard over the last
35 minutes or so our Deputy political
editor Sam Cates is here in the
Westminster studio with me
um Sam the Prime Minister this is last
but one before Christmas
um the Prime Minister being pushed by
kirstalmer again he seems to be going on
this weakness theme that he we've heard
in previous pmqs that the Prime Minister
seems to be flip-flopping seems to be
changing and starting off targeting them
on a sort of u-turn on housing that's
right another climb down from the Prime
Minister over housing targets last night
and kirst armor used that to return to a
theme that he's pursued in several of
the prime minister's question uh
exchanges with Rishi sumac
um he called kirstama called Richardson
at the blonde prime minister
if I've been completely honest it was a
bit of a blonde prime minister's
questions at the heart of these XJ as
always the the Kia style ma Rishi sunak
exchanges and and what kirstama did this
week is he hopped around there were uh
sort of four different subjects on the
table there were those housing targets
we were just talking about there was uh
Michelle moan uh the uh Tory pier and
what went on with PPE there was uh an
exchange about strikes and then there
were the deaths uh uh the strep a death
that he um uh that have been um claiming
lies lies very sadly all around the
country
um in recent days
um but and across all of that that meant
the political terms and not a great deal
of momentum was was was God up uh I
think
um there were a couple of sort of
striking news lines
um one was that uh effectively uh he
made clear that he would definitely
press ahead with strike new strike laws
he talked about new minimum service laws
when it comes to strike action uh and
challenge kirstama whether he would
support those we've got that at a clip
actually about strikes let's listen to
it
this morning his transport secretary
said that his Flagship legislation on
strikes this is what he said this
morning his transport secretary might
want to listen to this is clearly
clearly not going to help with the
industrial action we're facing he should
stop grandstanding stop sitting on his
hands get round the table and resolve
these issues and everyone can see what's
happening here a Tory politician got
their hands on hundreds of millions in
taxpayers money and then provided Duff
PPE and he says he's shocked he was the
chancellor
he he signed the checks
how much is he gonna get back
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker it's right that he brought up
legislation with regard to strike so I'm
very happy to address it actually so
hard-working families right now in this
country are facing challenges the
government has been reasonable it's
it is higher than the private sector but
if the union leaders to continue to be
unreasonable then it is my duty to take
action to protect the lives and
livelihoods of the British public and
that's why Mr Speaker since I became
prime minister I have been working for
new tough laws to protect people from
this disruption that's the legislation
he's asking about will he now confirm
that he'll stand up for working people
and that he and his party will back that
legislation
I mean case timer is on one level right
to say that the legislation that Rishi
sumac was just talking about at the end
of that section won't be ready in time
because it takes nine months to pass
legislation uh the train strikes for
instance are taking place next week
um there has been a hardening of the
line inside government in recent days
and it doesn't look as if they're going
to go beyond the kind of three four
percent
um pay offer that's currently on the
table for the rmt and other bits the
public sector the government doesn't
have a great deal of spare cash to throw
around as well as being concerned about
uh inflation and and the like so I I
think we are in for a grim few weeks
politically
the conservatives are just wondering
whether or not there isn't a potential
for tying Union activity to the labor
leadership not least there were donation
figures suggesting uh or showing that
the unions still continue to give to the
labor party uh that were released
yesterday but um it's an interesting
area whether or not the techniques that
the conservative government can adopt to
tighten the screw on union leaders start
to demonize and more start to threaten
them more uh actually do drive a wedge
between the public and the labor party
and the party currently 20 points ahead
in the polls as you were talking to the
MPS earlier we'll just have to wait and
see but it's uh it's a story that will
dominate the next three or four months
there's a secret though behind the
scenes in British politics because labor
party aren't saying they give huge
amounts more money uh match you know
what the unions want just as the
conservatives aren't and that's because
both sonnies are absolutely praying that
those independent forecasts about what's
going to happen to inflation do what
they say which is inflation around about
10 10 now but plunges to around three
percent by the end of next year and so
this issue about strikes goes away
because basically prices take care of
themselves so that's what both sides are
hoping may be this issue around strikes
is a is more temporary than anything
else but certainly in this wave of
industrial action new laws are a more
political gesture and dividing line than
they are something that are going to
help people get on with their lives okay
Sam thanks very much for taking us
through prime minister's questions
well let's look at some of the rest of
the day's news and the Kremlin has
denied suggestions it's planning a
second major offensive on Ukraine
warning critics to ignore provocative
messages online drone attacks thought to
be from the Ukrainian side have
continued to strike Farah into Russian
territory over recent days as the
battles for control rage on meanwhile
trench warfare continues on parts of the
front line of security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes sent this report
even tea breaks are treacherous here
the troops barely Flinch hardened by
months of War
with the front line quite literally
freezing they focus on different
priorities
to a point
that one was too near he says though
they still don't move there's some
really close incomes defended on the
road just above here so we're saying no
we all head for better cover
the Russian Artillery round slammed down
for nearly half an hour
we've had to take shelter because there
was too much incoming going on outside
we're not allowed to film well we are at
the moment but while we've been sitting
here we've heard explosions
up above making this whole shelter
shudder pretty terrifying and this is
what the soldiers have to go through
finally we're able to escape
a tense scram